>> DEMOCRATS AND THE LIBERAL
MEDIA LASHING OUT AT THE G.O.P.
OVER THE QUESTIONING OF
SUPREME COURT NOMINEE, JUDGE
KETANJI BROWN JACKSON, NOMINATED
FOR JUSTICE.
NETWORKS ARE ACCUSING REPUBLICAN
SENATORS OF RACISM, SEXISM, AND
A PET PET I LINK YOU PRESSING
HER ON HER RECORD HER RECORD.
>> JOSH HAWLEY AND SLAVEHOLDER
TO SEND TOM COTTON REPRISE DEREK
QANON BAITING SMEARS AGAINST
JUDGE KETANJI BROWN JACKSON.
>> THEY WERE TREATING HER LIKE A
BLACK SHOPPER.
>> GRANDSTANDING AND
SPEECHMAKING AND TO SEE FITTING
IN THE SENATE TODAY.
NO REPUBLICAN IS MORE HOT AND
BOTHERED THEN LINDSEY GRAHAM OF
SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> THIS IS ABOUT MIDTERM
ELECTIONS AND APPEALING TO
CULTURAL WARS, BILLING TO A
SEGMENT OF THE G.O.P. THAT IS
INTO CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
>> IN PARTICULAR
SENATOR BLACKBURN'S LINE OF
QUESTIONING, DID YOU SEE RACISM
IN ANY OF THAT?
>> AND BCS JOYLESS RAID NEVER TO
BE OUTSHOT WITH THE INSANITY.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHY THAT WAS
ALLOWED TO REMAIN ON THE
AIRWAVES AND THE HYPOCRISY IS
ABSOLUTELY MIND-BOGGLING.
NOT ONLY WAS I COMING OUT OF HER
MOUTH VERSUS A VILIFICATION THAT
OCCURS WHEN PEOPLE DARE TO
CRITIQUE OR ASSESS SOMEONE'S
HISTORY OF JURISPRUDENCE, BUT
ALSO THAT WE SEE IT AMPLIFIED IN
THE MEDIA.
AS THE CONTINUED COLLUSION
BETWEEN THE MEDIA, THE
WHITE HOUSE COMMEND THE
PROGRESSIVE LEFT, WHICH AS IF
YOU DARED TO CRITICIZE SOME OF
THE BACKGROUND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU ARE INSERTED RACIST,
MISOGYNISTIC, A MEMBER OF QANON,
ET CETERA FOR THAT SAME PHRASING
IS PARROTED BY THE WEB DELL MIKE
WHITE HOUSE BID THAT'S WE'VE
BEEN SEEING THROUGHOUT THE MEAT
HEARING FOR THE GREATEST LOSERS
ARE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL
COME OF THE VOTERS WHO DESERVE
TO BE IMPRESSED BY AND FULFILLED
BY WHATEVER FUTURE JUSTICE SITS
ON THE COURT.
INSTEAD THEY'VE BEEN TREATED TO
A CIRCUS ENTER DISGUSTING
COMMENTS LIKE THAT OF.
>> TOTALLY DISGUSTING.
ON ANOTHER NOTE YOU HAVE
SENATOR MARSHA BLACKBURN WITH A
VIRAL MOMENT OF THE WEEK.
>> CAN YOU PROVIDE A DEFINITION
FOR THE WORD WOMAN?
>> CAN I PROVIDE A DEFINITION?
NO.
I CAN'T.
>> YOU CAN'T?
>> NOT IN THIS CONTEXT I'M NOT A
BIOLOGIST.
>> I'M NOT A BIOLOGIST.
I SPOKE TO A BIOLOGIST IS
MORNING TO CONFIRM I AM STILL A
WOMAN.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M JUST SAYING.
THIS JUDGE WAS NOMINATED ON THE
BASIS OF HER SEX.
BIDEN NOMINATED HER BECAUSE SHE
WAS A WOMAN.
TAKE A STANCE FOR WOMEN.
AS A WOMAN I'M OFFENDED THAT SHE
DOESN'T KNOW WHO I AM.
WHO SHE IS, AND WHO ALL WOMEN
ARE.
AT THIS AMAZING HISTORICAL
CONTEXT IS NOT ONLY FOR A BLACK
WOMAN BUT A WOMAN TO BE
NOMINATED TO THE SUPREME COURT.
FOR MY INTENTS AND PURPOSES HAS
INSULTED ALL WOMEN ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> TOTALLY.
MEANWHILE PRESIDENT BIDEN KNEW
WHAT A WOMAN WAS BACK ON THE
CAMPING IN 2020.
WATCH.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT THE
SUPREME COURT.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO MAKING
SURE IS A BLACK WOMAN ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
I'M COMMITTED THAT IF I'M
ELECTED A PRESIDENT ALL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPOINT SOMEBODY
TO THE COURTS I WILL APPOINT THE
FIRST BLACK WOMAN TO THE COURTS.
I WILL ADD IN FACT APPOINT -- A
WOMAN TO BE VICE PRESIDENT.
>> SO, CARLEY, HE KNEW WHAT A
WOMAN WAS AT ONE POINT I WOULD
THINK.
>> I ALSO THINK IT'S IRONIC THAT
THE ROLE OF WOMANHOOD HAS PLAYED
SUCH A DEFINING ROLE IN BOTH
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH AND NOW JUDGE
JACKSON'S CONFIRMATION HEARINGS.
BACK IN 2018 WE ALL HAD TO
BELIEVE CHRISTIE BLASE FORD
BECAUSE SHE WAS A WOMAN AND WE
WERE IN THE TIME.
WHERE WE NEEDED TO BELIEVE ALL
WOMEN ARE AT FAST FORWARD FOUR
YEARS AND JUDGE JACKSON DOESN'T
WANT TO DEFINE THE TERM BECAUSE
IT COULD PIGEONHOLE HER INTO
TRANSGENDER ISSUES AND UPSET
PROGRESSIVES.
IT'S A VERY INTERESTING
POLITICAL TERM OF A VANS.
>> IT IS, YOU MENTION THE
BRETT KAVANAUGH HEARING.
THE EDITORIAL BOARD -- I HAD NO
DOUBLE CHECK THE SCUM OF THE
EDITORIAL BOARD HAD THIS TO SAY.
REPUBLICAN SAY THEY HAVE NOT
PULLED A BRETT KAVANAUGH COME IN
FACT THEY HAVE TREATED JACKSON
WORSE.
BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS CONVICTED OF
SERIAL GANG RAPE.
>> HAD MY BE NICE TO WRITE FOR
THE POST AND WAKE UP EVERY DAY
AS IF IT WAS THE FIRST DAY ON
EARTH AND NOTHING ELSE MATTERS.
THIS IS THE IDEA THAT SHE'S BEEN
TREATED WORSE THAN
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
I'M GOING TO SAY ONE THING, THE
LEFT WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE DO
THINGS WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
CONFIRMATION HEARING.
NUMBER ONE, THAT
KETANJI BROWN JACKSON IS
EXTREMELY QUALIFIED AND TO EVEN
QUESTION ANY OF THESE HISTORIES
OF WHAT SHE HAS DONE IS OUT AND
OUT RACIST.
BUT ALSO THEY WANT YOU TO
BELIEVE THAT SHE'S GOTTEN TO
THIS POINT AND SHE IS SO WEAK
THAT SHE'S GOING TO FOLD UNDER
THE BASIS OF TOUGH QUESTIONING.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
THIS WOMAN IS GOING TO THE
HIGHEST COURT OF THE LAND.
THIS IS A LIFETIME APPOINTMENT.
AFRICAN AMERICAN, BLACK WOMEN,
ET CETERA ARE AS STRONG AND
WILLING TO STAND UP AS ANYONE
ELSE.
STOP MAKING THOSE VICTIMS.
IT'S TIRED AND IT'S
DISRESPECTFUL TO US AND TO HER